there will be a lot of nervousness in
this in the civil service it across
Whitehall about the way that a u.s.
president was allowed to weaponize some
leaks in order to undermine a serving
diplomat and therefore causing situation
where he felt that he had to resign
there will be other senior diplomats and
senior civil servants up and down
Whitehall wondering whether or not they
too might suddenly find their future
less secure there all sorts of rumors
swirling about the current cabinet
secretary Sir Mark said dwells and what
he will do so let's hear from Tereza may
now this morning I have spoken to sue
kim Derek I have told him that it is a
matter of great regret that he has felt
it necessary to leave his position
[Applause]
the the whole cabinet rightly gave its
full support to skim on Tuesday so King
has given sir King has given a lifetime
of service to the United Kingdom and we
owe him an enormous debt of gratitude
good government depends on public
servants being able to give full and
frank advice I want all our public
servants to have the confidence to be
able to do that and I hope the house
will reflect on the importance of
defending our values and principles
particularly when they are under
pressure